foreign
[Music]
the Discovery Channel my name is Velma
Dinkley a necessary introduction of the
title characteration also is that orange
sweater just floating there is that the
mystery of the show will she ever solve
who's behind the case of the sartorial
levitation drawing eyelashes on what
looks to be a very uncomfortable bra
normally origin stories are about tall
handsome guys struggling with the burden
of being handed even more power trying
to draw attention away from the
patriarchy by immediately talking about
it is a bold move and we'll see if it
pays off just in case hey what made this
Hot Chip go crazy to get to the other
side jokes man how do they work I have
an idea instead of putting books on the
shelf that are blatant and unfunny jokes
scuba dues oh the hilarity maybe fill
the bookshelf with things that directly
speak to the individual quirks of the
character putting Post-it Note reminders
on the back of a recessed bookshelf is a
Surefire way to not see your post at no
reminders also isn't this a mask from
one of the OG Scooby-Doo villains isn't
this a prequel why does she have this
all already listen I gotta stop sending
this opening room scan and move on so
here's another 20 cents for how
ridiculous this whole setup is not Fred
and his weird sex fan after watching the
rest of this show we're all gonna come
back here and wonder if the van is weird
or the sex is weird also here's a sin
for me apparently watching the wrong
episodes of Scooby-Doo also also did
Velma hate Daphne did Velma hate anyone
I thought film this whole thing was to
be the steady intelligent one this CW
vacation of Velma is going to be really
super annoying isn't it and it starts
with a murder
calling your audience names throwing
your sleep mask onto a 50-foot High
electric wire how would you even launch
it that high and why
this school sucks and apparently don't
forget about these [__] roaches I
mean roaches [__] trust me this is a
subtle foreshadowing of a human mating
ritual cell conversation that will take
place in just a moment so let's not rush
past this pest smash also shaming
Roaches for doing what most animals do
naturally although cockroaches don't
technically do it exactly like that the
male roach distracts the female roach
with a gift of food and then uses one
penis to lock onto them and the other
one to deliver the goods that's right
they're technically double cockroaches
team shower discussion topic of the day
team shower discussion topics happy ever
noticed how pilot episodes of TV shows
always have more gratuitous sex and
nudity no but I have noticed that you
walked into the shower spray while
leaving your towel on which will cease
to make it a functional towel also this
Meadow wink at the fact that this takes
place in the girls locker room with
shower Pals is completely undermined by
the sheer amount of physics defying
nipple bubbles I'm not asking for full
frontal nudity for the sake of the joke
I'm just asking you to maybe not make
the dump joke in the first place then
why was your favorite part of the
Riverdale pilot when Betty and Veronica
kiss well because
I called I'm tired in the scene but it
was also called taboo faux lesbian
kissing hasn't been to boo since 1994.
taboo if you're gonna TV sends please do
it properly just didn't it we are all
secretly pervert since perversion
suggests a deviation from a norm we by
definition can't all be perverts and
since secrecy suggests that the info is
hidden I must ask if you've seen the
internet recently this is going to be
the type of thing people are just okay
with in the show for some reason show
clearly thinks violent sells as well but
chooses to go off brand and not have a
shower diatribe about it and how do you
feel about race Point casting Daphne is
Velma making fun of woke culture or
actually a part of woke culture it's
actually kind of impressive how the show
skirts the line just enough to allow
everyone to hate it equally everyone
loves it when white people play Jesus or
a professional boxer why can't it ever
go the other way right is having a naked
dripping wet woman discuss this while
being assaulted meant to be Progressive
because now I'm afraid of progress and
that's entirely the show's fault I
wasn't expecting such an enlightened
answer from such
um
it was Velma the entire time listen if
you're gonna Scooby-Doo your protagonist
reveal it should be a reveal and not
just a confirmation of the viewer's
Assumption also is the goal to make
Velma the least likable protagonist in
the history of Television because bang
up job crew seeing now if this was a
show it'd be super hot is you two kissed
oh well let me just jot that down not uh
show got it
brain oh I'm not dissing her she has no
brain everyone can see the brainless
girl Velma so why would anybody be
doubting you the attempts at humor in
this show are so unfunny that I almost
feel bad for piling on by saying the
jokes also don't make any logical sense
can't you hear the regret in my voice as
I add 35 sins
and I wasn't lurking
with gloves a
and a voice modulator I'll never
understand women in their toiletry
supplies no because I hate your stupid
adopted daughter and her fake ass
friends so the police team they sent in
to interrogate her are the moms of her
classmate has no one here heard of a
conflict of interest as in I'm
experiencing zero conflict about my
complete lack of Interest as to where
any of this is going and yet you and
Daphne used to be best friends isn't
that right most shows or movies at least
give the tiniest bit of effort to hide
blatant Exposition but not Velma velma's
like let's have the police fill in the
backstory through interrogation and
random personal photos that have nothing
to do with the case that are
consecutively inserted into the case
file for reasons you got 24 hours and
then we arrest you because we're not
just great at forced Exposition we're
also really good at [__] ticking
clock tension set up also was she not
already under arrest why was she
handcuffed to the table
[Music]
taking over two hours to walk out of the
police station also the hoodie she just
had in the interrogation room has
suddenly gone missing by the time she
gets outside of the police station
unnecessarily adding to the list of
Unsolved Mysteries you cheat off me in
Spanish because you think I'm Mexican
maybe I have a disease where I can't
recognize people who aren't hot what you
need to know is that Fred is a bigot and
probably a racist but still hot enough
for Velma to Swoon over and as far as
the episode's concerned there'll be no
lessons learned about the dangers of
thinking with your dinkly also was the
idea to make me hate the entire
Scooby-Doo team because bang up job crew
you're not real you're not real my exact
reaction every three minutes watching
this show somehow makes it into the
episode I'm not
a basic [__] who doesn't even know how
to use hashtag no
check the owner of spooners don't forget
that you're also the newest character to
be introduced that we won't care about
in the slightest because you're a
vehicle for exposition and thematic
cliches first in a person second babies
with xenomorphic Tendencies
[Music]
scene contains neither magic nor Mike
she was the rare [__] that did not
deserve to be murder what the [__] I
honestly don't even know that I'm needed
here wait so after she screamed earlier
about suddenly being told she had a
surprise job she didn't want she decided
to do it anyway can anyone in the show
make a normal human decision all these
roaches will disappear in a moment
making their threat purely symbolic
are you sure because it feels like feels
like the animators conjured you from
thin air considering no one was behind
the dumpster a moment ago I'm trying to
pull myself together so I can be the man
my father expects me to be Zam dilf City
hashtag preloading your insta post so
you can force a dilf joke like the case
of the missing idea juice we've got
alcoholism jokes y'all I have no clue as
to what not ACLU could possibly mean so
I put on my mom's glasses and vowed I
wouldn't open her gift until I found her
teasing us with the idea that this gift
could be key to everything along with
the idea that you'd be able to find your
way out of this room while wearing
prescription glasses now when I try to
solve a mystery my guilt triggers a
potentially heart-stopping hallucination
show handles its own plot points like
cliche is almost like it's trying to be
the TV and send it at the same time
guess I'll just [__] off then no wait I
think I'll give it 15 cents in Forge
ahead that's what velma's Mom would want
wow after hearing that I not only feel
emotionally hooked I understand the
stakes of your journey Velma you see
it's funny because it's false Thelma
there you are please don't tell me that
shaggy that guy is way too cool to be
Shaggy Norville phew hold on a second
just need to Google something real quick
well
damn it Norville you're wasting my time
show has time for Velma having time for
norvel having time for this on TV shows
The Malt Shop owner is always a friendly
black man or a spicy and meatball
Italian just say the specific shows
you're talking about and save the
viewers some time Velma is actively
being horrible at TV sins also assuming
black men aren't spicy and Italians
aren't friendly I think it has something
to do with drugs which I hate
dear show and I do not say this without
a reasonable amount of genuflection and
consideration go [__] yourself uh
well dorkus was
in a later episode I'll remove Us in
until then there will be no benefit of
the doubt for this show no I know Brenda
was murdered to keep that photograph
from getting out you don't know this you
suspect it I thought you were like
suggesting a date a date you wish the
show acts like the only thing we wanted
from the OG Scooby Doo is everyone on
the team begging to do each other okay
I'm not saying that hasn't crossed
anyone's mind but I am saying this
[__] probably wasn't what they
imagined when it did I thought you
killed Brenda because she figured out
the secret to your Diner's popularity I
get that but there isn't any secret to
it just good food great tunes and I let
teens have sex in the bathroom using the
Digital Underground Burger King
marketing plan I don't know why she
would have been so upset about having
her Pages ruined by these drawings this
one literally starts with lorem ipsum
Mom wasn't taken she left because
she hated us it's also possible she went
to see a specialist for her eye but they
operated on the wrong one and now she's
blind in both eyes so when she was
driving home which absolutely seems like
something that would be allowed to
happen in Crystal Cove she drove off the
road then upon realizing how silly it
was to be driving in the first place she
wandered off into the woods in search of
help where she happened upon a chemical
plant unfortunately she lost her footing
tripped and fell face first into a
puddle which turned out to be run off
from the chemical plant but instead of
being harmed she was imbued with
superpowers after which her only choice
was to move to New York and become
Daredevil for example and you can start
changing your personality to fit
was this option on the table the whole
time or is it just been completely
fabricated because the writer saw
something like this in a different show
one time thought it was Dumb and decided
to include it as a joke this outfit is
you're not a brain room moving serial
killer anymore and other things you
would say to a serial killer in a world
with consequences that none of the
characters care about who's carrying a
tomato around before first Bell a banana
peel I understand but a tomato
underneath this banging new Luke new
Luke I learned this is not a creature
capable of murder nay it is just a
scared little boy who wants our
friendship Fred being the hero this city
deserves and that it doesn't deserve one
well well well
well well now
even the show is trying to dispose of
its jokes in real time using the hot
bacteria distribution machine to dry
your hands sure if someone was like want
to see a naked picture of Fred I'd be
like but I say that about anyone waiting
until the end of the episode to make
your protagonist relatable norfol really
hates drugs to like a suspicious degree
of all the idiocy in the show the most
egregious is that anyone would give
someone a boost by placing their hands
on the ground under their heel you make
them step into your interlocked fingers
at about knee height so that you get the
momentum of that in your first step up
this is not rocket science norvel
although that also involves boosters so
I get the confusion I'm bored same here
just remember these hallucinations are
only in your head they also do seem
terrible and do generate some empathy
for the character so I'd like to give
the writer some credit here and take
back one quarter of a sin but it also
goes on for so long that it's absurd
that no one in this house has heard her
screams or happened upon her rolling
around on the ground and I like to round
up so have you seen any good movies
lately oh God here comes the big one
I haven't seen that one it sounds like
one I might enjoy
the only instructions the creators of
the show were given by HBO somehow
cringes its way into the episode Thelma
takes a picture of us because the fourth
wall is only a suggestion but the joke's
on her because that's not how TVs work
you can't take a picture of me right how
are these two bad cops this good at
shooting that they could hit him in both
his legs at the exact same height and by
bat cop I mean they're bad at being cops
not malicious or corrupt cops just
making sure you understand since the
show has inspired me to over explain the
exact point all the time I'd like to
watch Fred's like blood out of my mouth
Fred's Lake blood was never in your
mouth liar man if I found humor
attractive I would be all over you right
now oh well if I found this show
humorous I'd be excited for the next
episode oh well the rules feel a bit
muddy with all the hardcore fourth wall
action going on it's hard not to feel
like this is the writers talking to us
which would be fine if they hadn't made
the rules muddy and then bragged about
it oh sorry I'm not a drunk on the verge
of losing custody like every other woman
solving murders these days seriously I
usually don't let people pound my fourth
wall this much without at least buying
me dinner first clearly I hallucinated
because I do still feel guilty there is
nothing clear about this show its
existence or its hallucinations
the funniest joke in this whole show is
that it thinks a cliffhanger could get
me to watch another single solitary
second of this travesty
oh Velma you're a hoot
IE mystery solvers that's a mystery I
don't solve Mysteries
anymore first mystery I ever solved my
mother wrote Mysteries little Mysteries
to solve taught mysteries of my own my
mystery song solve you're a mystery can
I try to solve a mystery trying to solve
a mystery and keep trying to solve a
mystery to solve the mystery stop
feeling guilty about your Mysteries baby
I realized solving Mysteries did the guy
trying to solve a mystery get off my
truck and let me solve this mystery it
was my mystery solving that is one
mystery
they've ruined my childhood my name is
[Music]
Velma that's not fair I'm not just a
waitress I'm also a client but Brenda
wasn't just a rare [__] she was the old
[__] [__] Phoenix dragons but instead of
feeling excited I found my Christmas
presents I felt terrible you ruined
Jasmine oh my god Becky look at her butt
no time driving a friend's house nah
Miss Daisy you need the chauffeur oh
wait this isn't so bad no it's not bad
Velma oh you're scared yet